good afternoon everyone at the turn of
the century the Surgeon General issued a
call to action urging all Americans to
fight obesity building on a deep-rooted
culture of fat hatred and thin worship
the public health campaign soon
mushroomed into a giant war on fat in
which not just medical and public health
authorities but every segment of society
and all of us as individuals are engaged
in constant fat talk aimed at educating
badgering and shaming heavy people into
shedding pounds you could say that
America has become a veritable fat
chopped nation a place in which fat
related conversation imagery videos and
so forth are in inescapable parts of our
social and built landscapes we hear a
great deal about the health and economic
costs of obesity to the country yet
possible human costs of the fight
against that are almost never mentioned
the project I'm about to describe came
about through sheer serendipity in 2010
and 2011 I was teaching a class on the
body in American culture at UC Irvine
and I offered my students extra credit
for writing a personal essay on diet
weight in the BMI in everyday life I was
absolutely stunned by what they
described young lives mostly devastated
by struggles over weight this was not
part part of the story of childhood
obesity in America I felt compelled to
take their essays some 250 and all
seriously as a data source to see what
they revealed using the essays I first
sought to understand how the war on fat
plays out on the ground in American
culture
I found fatness is not primarily about
health more fundamentally it's about
morality and political inclusion or
citizenship wealth in fit people are
celebrated as good bio citizens that
people are deserved are deemed
undeserving of membership in the
community of valued Americans as bio
citizens our duties are to diet exercise
and maintain
await ourselves and to use that talk to
persuade others to do the same
first informative or pedagogical fat
talk and then if that doesn't work
abusive fat talk designed to shame them
into losing weight such pressures might
be ethical with diet and exercise led to
sustained weight loss but mostly they do
not despite enormous progress in
understanding the biology of obesity
efforts to find safe effective means to
prevent and treat it have not yet
yielded satisfactory results in a larger
context in which being thin is equated
with being a good American the
combination of few means with strong
pressures has produced troubling effects
looking at those effects I first delved
into the issue of selfhood showing how
the weight classes of the BMI have been
internalized in such a way that people
of all sizes increasingly define
themselves by their weight category the
ethnography showed how both obese and
overweight youngsters subject to abusive
fat talk developed a self-loathing
emotionally troubled quote that
personhood being heavy was so damaging
because they told they had a disease
which men their bodies were defective
and because they were considered bad
Americans
hence legitimate targets of social
rejection then and even normal-sized
kids developed spoiled identities to
what these essays showed is the
emergence of the first war on fat
generation a generation obsessed with
their bodies and whose most fundamental
sense of self comes from their size big
or small
everyone was miserable about their
bodies and almost no one was able to
lose weight and keep it off pressure to
lose weight no matter what many young
people took weight loss practices to an
extreme in the process damaging their
health I documented a veritable epidemic
of dangerous weight loss practices that
resulted in bodily harm raging from
short-term problems such as loss of
consciousness to longer-term damage to
the musculoskeletal system for example
the vast majority developed disorder
reading while some went further sliding
down the slippery slope into eating
disorders and the fat talk by a
citizenship approach to fighting fat did
not even work and not one case of the
very fat person did the cajoling and
bullying of goodbye of citizens in their
lives help them lose weight okay so what
are the take-home points what does this
book add to what we already know first
we know that stigma is growing worse and
that the pervasive weight bias and
discrimination in our society are
harming the social and economic
prospects of heavy people my work goes
further to show that our current
approach harms not just fat people but
potentially people of every size second
we know that stigma and shaming are
damaging by locating these within a
larger social theory my work shows that
these ways of treating people are
culturally legitimate simply what is
expected of a good bio citizen
eradicating fat shaming will be harder
than is now thought third if these
stories are typical and much evidence
suggest they are then the fight against
that might be causing untold damage to
children and teens even after losing
weight many will never outgrow the
feeling of being damaged goods
many will carry the scars avoid abuse
into later life finally in our
evaluations of obesity interventions the
human costs of our efforts deserve a
place alongside to the economic costs of
obesity itself since few of these have
even been named little own measured and
tallied up there's much work to be done
and I hope social scientists can team up
with medical scientists in taking the
next step in the meantime we need a
cultural revolution even a scientific
research on obesity continues we need a
revolution in the culture aimed at a
brooding fat talk stopping fat abuse in
dethroning weight as a central measure
of human values thank you